enforcement officer is under new
pressure from President Trump mr. Trump
yesterday stepped up his attacks on
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he
refused to say whether sessions job is
safe the president took the stage last
night before a friendly audience at a
rally in Ohio and touted his own
leadership style sometimes they say he
doesn't act presidential with the
exception of the late great Abraham
Lincoln I can be more presidential than
any president that's ever held this
office that I can tell you
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with what she can tell us about the
president marking a milestone in off his
market good morning good morning well
the president returned to the campaign
trail to find refuge from the turmoil
here in Washington and as you heard he
defended his unconventional approach
with that trademark hype hyperbole is
there any place that's more fun more
exciting and safer than a Trump rally
nearly 300 miles from Washington
President Trump supporters cheered him
but cameras also caught protesters
getting manhandled on the way to the
exit well he's a young one he's gone
back home to mommy
during the campaign style rally the
president made just brief references to
the Senate's move to open debate on
health care he issued a warning to
senators considering voting against the
bill any senator who votes against
repeal and replace is telling America
that they are fine with the Obamacare
nightmare and I predict they'll have a
lot of problems
he also touted an announcement made
Tuesday by his embattled Attorney
General Jeff Sessions my administration
is launching a nationwide crackdown on
sanctuary cities but didn't cite his
name or give him credit
the president's frustration with
sessions decision to recuse himself from
the Russia investigation was laid bare
at an earlier news conference he should
have told me prior to taking office and
I would have quite simply picked
somebody else
it was sessions recusal that eventually
led to the appointment of Special
Counsel Robert Muller the president has
not forgiven sessions and was asked why
he does not fire him we will see what
happens time will tell but firing
sessions could be interpreted as an
attempt to obstruct Muller's
investigation and it could alienate
sessions former colleagues Utah
Republican Orrin Hatch jeff has been
very loyal to the president I think he
deserves
now sessions received near unanimous
support from Republicans on Capitol Hill
and he's shown no signs of resigning
Gail if he did or if he was fired
president Trump could appoint a
replacement while Congress is out of
town but Democrats including Leader
Chuck Schumer have vowed to block him
from doing that all right everybody's
watching Thank You Margaret